[Musique]
tous
merci à luis dozen nous réunir merci
évidemment la pe parce que l'animation
et dieu sait qu on a aujourd'hui
l'animation des écoles se fait bien
évidemment souvent par le bénévolat de
l'association de parents d'élèves est
donc un grand merci à vous c'est un
temps exceptionnel c'est un moment
exceptionnel que nous vivons ici tu pour
une femme exceptionnelle et donc ravi
d'avoir partagé ce moment là avec vous
merci de votre attention
je vais profiter de cette inauguration
ce matin purin jaune de l'école tourisme
n'osait pour adresser un message de
remerciements à l'ensemble des
enseignants de notre pays parce que il
grâce à eux les enfants et 13 millions
d'enfants sur la river ont pu traverser
ces quinze derniers mois qui ont été
difficiles pour tous les familles et
évidemment nos enfants et donc il a
fallu assurer le distanciait la reprise
des cours le subit des protocoles donc
vraiment à tous les enseignants de
france un grand merci
[Musique]